is a Turkish military assault on Kurdish
forces on the horizon a Turkish TV
station has broadcast images of what it
says is a convoy of Turkish military
vehicles heading to the border with
Syria Ankara have used the Kurdish
military in northern Syria as terrorists
and has threatened military action
Kurdish forces have been left vulnerable
after that shock announcement that their
ally the United States will withdraw all
its troops from Syria and they've
requested help the Syrian government has
now sent troops to the flashpoint town
of maan beach setting the scene for a
potential shutdown joining me now in
studio is Daniel Garlock he's the editor
in chief of zenith magazine which
focuses on Middle Eastern affairs
so if Syrian forces are indeed in mine
beach could this be a game-changer in
the Civil War no I don't think so I
don't think it's going to be a
game-changer I think this has been much
more of a symbolic move and we're seeing
actually a repetition of the scenario of
the second Turkish military offensive
about a year ago - the canton of Afreen
where the Kurdish forces had called for
help from the Syrian regime and the
Syrian regime symbolically moved
incentives and some militias put the
Syrian national flag and said now we're
in control of of mamb bush and somehow
they could also be a face-saving
solution for the Turks because Turkey
now can buy time and doesn't have to
move in as it promised what about the
Kurds so that the Kurds have now asked
Syrian troops to move into that that
city what do they want why ask for those
troops
well the Kurdish forces have paid dearly
when they conquered ma'am - a couple of
years ago from the so-called Islamic
state militias and this was they lost
about 300 people so this was a highly
symbolic victory for them and since then
ma'am which has been contested area the
map which is a strategic location
because from the if you if you conquer
map which you can enter both Cordish
contents or both areas that are still
held by the Kurdish forces in the East
you're very close to the shores of the
Euphrates River and therefore it's a
strategic place
and it's it's very important to keep
this and it's also very important for
the Turkish forces of course to take it
if they want to defeat the YPG the
Kurdish militias but if the Syrian
regime says we are now officially in
control of it then this is at least a
political victory for adarand because a
military offensive in this area would be
very costly for them because I don't
think the Kurds are going to give this
away easily
president Erdogan you mentioned him he's
been sending his own forces to the
border what do you think I mean you
mentioned this before but how likely is
a Turkish attack it's been announced
several times not specifically a
Mandapam ambush we have French troops in
the area we also have Russian troops in
the area we have the Syrian regime so
mambas itself has not been announced by
the weather by the Turkish presidents
specifically but an intervention in the
eastern part in northeastern part of
Syria where we have a lot of oil and gas
resources and a lot of Turkish Kurdish
troops are in control of this area this
has been of course a strategical for
Turkey and what I think they're going to
do is they're going to try to provoke an
uprising of Arab tribes against the
Kurdish forces there that are very
discontent with the situation there with
the control of the Kurds and they are
trying to I think more an indirect
approach but of course they could
continue cross-border operations aerial
operations in this area but I don't
think I'm not sure if we will see a
heavy like full fledged military offense
in this area now about 20 seconds where
does this leave the u.s. now I was not
surprised by the withdrawal of the US
troops to be honest and I think let's
hope that the US have talked to the
Turks about it and to the Russians about
it but I think America has taken itself
deliberately out of the game at the
moment it could continue aerial attacks
or whatever to be in the game militarily
but you can say politically they have
withdrawn completely and deliberately so
I know Gary Locke thank you very much
for being with us thank you